moscú ha comenzado a distribuir la
vacuna sputnik 5 a través de 70 clínicas
arranca así la primera vacunación masiva
contra el coronavirus en rusia
la vacuna rusa se administra en dos
inyecciones y rusia asegura que pronto
tendrá listas 2 millones de dosis el
grupo de trabajo que está al frente de
la vacuna ha anunciado que los primeros
en recibirla van a ser los médicos
enfermeros y también otras profesiones
con riesgo de contagio como los
trabajadores sociales o los maestros las
encuestas sin embargo dicen que la mayor
parte de los rusos no está pensando
precisamente en ponerse la vacuna ni la
vacuna rusa ni ninguna otra la vacuna
está desarrollada por el centro de
investigación gamma leia de moscú y
tiene una eficacia del 95 por ciento
según las autoridades pero eso son
resultados preliminares sobre
voluntarios a los que se les inyectó y
se les hizo la prueba después de 42 días
la capital rusa vive una segunda ola
estos días
moscú es el epicentro del brote de
coronavirus en rusia con 8.000 nuevos
casos cada día unas cifras que empeoran
en bastante las de septiembre cuando
había 700 nuevos casos cada día
la vacuna es la principal esperanza para
no tener que encerrar a la población